well the governor of Florida Ronda
Sanchez has officially entered the 2024
Republican race for the U.S White House
and I'm running for president to lead
our Great American comeback
he released this campaign video after
making the announcement on Twitter's
live audio streaming platform that that
event alongside Elon Musk faced major
technical issues and had to be abandoned
for nearly half an hour DeSantis will
take on his one-time backer Republican
front-runner Donald Trump as well as
several other candidates well critics of
DeSantis say under his leadership the
State of Florida has become openly
hostile towards people of color and the
lgbtq plus Community Mike Hannah reports
now from Washington DC
[Music]
Ron DeSantis had just turned 40 when he
was first elected governor of Florida
endorsed by the then president Donald
Trump he won by the narrowest of margins
but he was re-elected three years later
in a landslide evidence of the massive
conservative support built up as
governor and an indication of the swing
that seen Florida move from a toss-up
state to solidly Republican because of
our leadership and the folks in our
state we've really become the Beating
Heart of the conservative movement in
these United States donation
reimbursement schema the scientist's
policies have shifted little over the
years as a member of Congress and
Governor his dislike of big government
was evidenced in his resistance to
Federal covert regulations a Hardline
stance on immigration and abortion is
welcomed by many core Republicans
and he's on the front lines of what has
emerged as a national cultural war on
everything from Progressive education
policies to entertainment we do not
surrender to the woke mob Florida's
where woke goes to die
but his so-called war on awoke has
potential downsides particularly the
governor's retaliation against
entertainment giant Disney that
criticized part of his education
legislation as homophobic he withdrew
the company's tax breaks setting off a
legal dispute and some Republican
strategists believe it's something he
may regret I think that's a that's a
that's a grave miscalculation uh in the
long run
um you know the powers of of government
should never be used to go after an
individual company right especially for
political reasons uh you can have a
confrontation uh but to to Really call
out and go after I think as an overuse
of of his power there DeSantis is likely
to fight for the Republican nomination
against his one-time backer Donald Trump
who has come up with a demeaning
nickname for his opponent and that's
Rhonda sanctimonious and you've been
watching him for all his falling at
record levels and we'll keep it that way
there are the candidates taking on
Donald Trump for the Republican
nomination but at this stage it appears
that only this Yale and Harvard Law
School graduate has a viable chance
Mike Hannah Al Jazeera Washington
well Adolfo Franco is a Republican
strategist and he says DeSantis will
have to distinguish himself from Trump
amongst Republican voters
the fact is to date none of the credible
candidates for the Republican nomination
have disagreed with President Trump in
any meaningful way on any policy issues
and in fact have defended president
Trump uh with respect to the political
and legal persecution that is going on
persecution that is going on in New York
and Washington and in Georgia at some
point Governor DeSantis is going to have
to say things that differ with President
Trump or certainly criticize president
Trump more more fully if he hopes to get
any traction he is a governor he's
extraordinarily been extraordinarily
successful he's had a very distinguished
military record
um he's had a good record in Congress as
a conservative and of course was
reelected in in Florida it might be
trending red but he carried counties and
constituencies in Florida that we
haven't carried as Republicans in over
20 years the problem is that the
nomination is the primary process is
decided by core conservative Republicans
and the vast majority of Republicans
identify very closely personally with
President Trump they're loyal to him as
a person uh in the first instance and
secondly have a suspicion that other
than president Trump everybody's saying
what they need to say but president
Trump actually believes it and the other
Republican candidates are merely stating
things that they believe the Republican
primary voters want to hear but in their
core are willing to compromise on those
principles